Fitness is really entertaining to me and
it's what's kept me like I've usually
don't wear a SmartWatch for very long
but I think it's been about a month and
I just keep like so there's a feature
net where you can challenge people to a
one week long challenge to whoever burns
the most calories and has the most
points or whatever like a point system
right and that gamification of fitness
has been I think pretty special it's
been pretty good well this contest has
been really crazy with me and my friends
so what are you trying to do well we if
the winner is going to get a belt like a
WWE style belt nice it says
intergalactic sober October champion and
it has like marijuana leaf or the line
through it and a bottle of booze will
line through it and you wear these
things it's uh it's called a my zone and
it it works with an app it works pretty
good and it registers your amount of
your heart rate the amount of calories
you burn and it gives you a point system
and the point system is I don't know
what what they call its MEP s I don't
know what it stands for but this the
amount of points over the month is what
everyone's shooting for right and so
today we're at October the 23rd so we
have eight days to go and I have worked
out more in these 23 days than I have in
like the last six months and I'm not
exaggerating yeah I put in five and a
half hours yesterday hard I got more
than 900 points then after the podcast I
said [ __ ] it we're gonna go for another
hundred and I worked out and I got
another hundred points put in another
hour
yeah it's maniacal because you see you
actually see the number and because I
can see the number I can see all my
friends numbers
yeah and I'm Way ahead so on what I'm
just keep telling them to I'm twisting
the blade because I'm so far ahead like
right now I am fifteen hundred points
away from everybody else okay
Oberth trying to work out again that
slob so when you see somebody catching
up here like glad that I hit the gym
exactly yeah
and so I'm planning on staying so far
ahead that they must die in order to
beat me the iPhone or the Apple watch
when you have people connected with the
fitness part of it it will literally
notify me when one of my friends has
finished a workout and tell me like how
good their were how many points they
just got like as they finish it like you
hit the finish button and you know
everyone's getting a notification yes
that's interesting so I'm gonna put in
the extra four or five miles on the bike
so they get that notification that I did
that and that really does work
yeah I mean there's no doubt about it
yeah just having that external
motivating factor and then seeing a
number there's something about like with
this with the MEPS em EPS whatever the
[ __ ] that stands for that stands for and
I don't know how the Apple watch
measures points either I think there's a
because it's measuring I mean if there's
a lot of sensors in this thing so not
only is a heartrate monitor there's an
accelerometer and a gyroscope so it
knows when you're standing those when
you're moving quickly and I it basically
just comes up with a points number at
the end of the day I every time I fly I
just don't get any points because I just
sit there right but yet there's like a
live counter constantly going of like
you and your friends and you got to have
the highest number so out of all the
stuff that you do during my own effort
points that's what it is that's the maps
points but here's the thing about that
Maps points and we were trying to figure
out why it does it gives you the same
amount of points for 80% of your max
heart rate as it does for 90 so like the
first day I said I'm just gonna sprint
and try to bury these guys so I put them
in 90 percent for 35 minutes I was like
they can't do that I'm just gonna do
some [ __ ] they can't do but it doesn't
give you any more points for 90 percent
90 percent gives the exact amount of
points is 80%
so it's thrown propriety those two
they're fires piece of [ __ ] so it's so
dumb
so I think the reason why they did that
is to keep people from killing
themselves that's what I think yeah just
get somewhere in the 80 to 90 brain fat
Bert is always in the two and three fat
Bert never gets in yellow that's slob
he's just waddling around waddling
around with blue and green mostly gray
he gets a lot of gray he'll get gray for
hours just waddle and complaining
thinking about vodka dreaming about food
he's gonna watch this and hit the gym I
mean he's on the gym gym right now he's
at the gym right now I'm trying to catch
up so he's playing catch up yeah the
thing you gotta stay ahead he's gonna
stay ahead but yeah when you fall behind
in the distance you think of them as
wolves barking in the distance chasing
you like no [ __ ] way not eating me
[ __ ] wolves ten miles away or not gonna
get you but wolves a hundred yards away
they got to keep the distance ten mile
way too far ten miles that you want to
hear he's saying least just slob he's
gonna double everything I do look at
that fat face that's not even possible
stop before I throw up
yes a dog he's so far behind it's
impossible to win but that's the point
the point is to keep the keep the boot
on his neck yeah this is this only does
seven-day challenges so you basically
like you get you start it and they
accept and then it counts for the next
seven days all your cumulative points um
well that would be good then you just do
four maybe just keep going yeah yeah
that's I like the challenge aspect of it
it's it's really I mean all jokes aside
it's been really fun yeah with my
friends poor Tommy bunts way behind know
what's going on Tom Segar is way behind
he's like 1800 points behind storm him
up is he like saving a couple days might
be he might be saying [ __ ] comes full
strength all day you sort you store them
up and you're in this device and then
you sink so you could pretend that
you're not doing any work
I could sandbag yes no one knows then
the last day you look you son of a [ __ ]
Joe's online he's 10,000 points ahead
real issue so the key is just keep the
work rate at an almost impossible level
so like yesterday like I said I worked
out five and a half hours and then
another hour
yeah and today I've already put in two
hours and put in two hours at seven
o'clock this morning
so hotel room doesn't have any the thing
is I'm putting two hours in at yellow
I'm hitting 80% for two hours fat birds
out there waddling around with his dog
pretending he's working hard making
videos that's he's got like gray and a
little bit of blue he may be green
little green then he takes a break
cries numbers are low near they're lower
than mine that's a fact I worked out
more yes last night and this morning
than he has in the whole day
the other thing No